what's going on guys this is robin in
this video we're going to cover a story
where spider-man kills everyone
and this story is amazing
i love this story so much it is dark
it's like the darkest spider-man story
ever although i imagine craven's last
hunt might really take the cake for
those of you guys who are experienced
with spider-man reading when we're done
with this let me know which one of the
two you think is darker now for those of
you guys who are unfamiliar with our
spider-verse coverage up to this point
because i imagine we might gain a little
bit of traction based on the popularity
of the trailer which is releasing
tonight at 8 30 p.m at the time that i'm
recording this video the edge of spidey
verse event was part of the larger
spider-verse story right where you had a
whole bunch of different spider-man from
across the multiverse who were teaming
up against a group called the inheritors
edge of spider-verse basically gave us
these little stories dealing with
different spider-men from across the
multiverse some of whom actually
survived into the main spider-verse
event and some of whom did not for
various reasons this one actually picks
up with a kid named patton parnell
instead of peter parker the traditional
name and right off the bat right like
right off the bat clayton mcleod the guy
who wrote this story basically shows us
that this kid is dark right like he
finds an ant uses a magnifying glass and
basically kills the thing but one of the
things about this is he's not like some
you know six-year-old kid who does it
out of curiosity or something like that
he actually is showing signs of
psychopathy if not sociopathy right like
anti-social personality disorder a
sociopath or psychopath right the idea
of harming things that are basically
defenseless that that's really the kind
of air that he puts off more so than
that though it doesn't really seem to be
done out of malice or cruelty it really
seems to be done more out of curiosity
and that's one of the big differences
between peter and like a traditional
psychopath or a traditional sociopath is
that he doesn't really have a desire to
harm people for the sake of doing it
it's really more of like a science
experiment than anything else and so
what he actually ends up doing or at
least in this time when he's in his room
he's got a got a pair of binoculars and
he's basically spying on a girl named
sarah jane who is in effect mary jane
watson right just by a different name
and it's one of these things where he
actually refers to her as like as an
experiment of sorts so right there
you've got a kind of detachment right
where he doesn't necessarily see himself
as being a human despite living among
humans right like being a human himself
that he sees himself as kind of
different now this would become hugely
important once you get to like the
traditional mythos as far as spider-man
goes and all that kind of stuff but the
way that he speaks here is like
commencing surveillance experiment
stakeout number 16 right subject remains
unaware of being under observation
perfect
so he's basically spying on her as she's
getting undressed right he's like i must
collect samples from subjects living
area for analysis right and then at that
point his uncle basically starts
shouting at him and telling him you know
he's got to drive him to school and all
that kind of stuff but once he gets
there of course again his interactions
with mary jane watson and we're just
going to go ahead and call her that
right you know we're going to call him
peter parker we're going to call her
mary jane watson we're going to keep it
simple here but i mean they are
alternate reality characters they do
have their alternate reality names but
they're by all standards of measurement
peter parker or mary jane watson right
so we'll just go ahead and call him that
so basically mary jane kind of asked
peter parker to sit down next to him
right now on the surface this is not a
very big thing but for those of you guys
who come from a background of being like
socially awkward or lacking the kind of
social skills necessary to talk to girls
this is something that's kind of huge
right i mean i used to be a socially
awkward guy back in the day if you can
believe it or not when i when i say back
in the day i mean like when i first
started middle school right like i'd say
within like a year or two of middle
school i was awesome but up until that
point
[Laughter]
i was kind of socially awkward right but
the thing about this is that if you come
from that kind of background you
understand the struggle of like just
striking up a conversation with a person
in general let alone a girl you like
right the idea behind this is they're
basically going to a place called alcor
right which is basically this kind of uh
what you would normally expect with
peter parker receiving is his
radioactive spider bite right in that
particular location and that's exactly
what happens now of course as you also
expect if you're familiar with the
existing spider-man mythos mary jane
watson is basically in with flash
thompson now it didn't historically work
this way but it's one of the things
where it's basically the love interest
of peter parker is dating the school
bully right and so because of that one
of the things to know this is something
that i think a lot of young people
struggle with why do girls like bullies
or why do girls like guys who are jerks
because they exude confidence man like
they are just they're some of the most
confident people you're ever going to
find and one of the things that you will
learn over the course of your life is
confidence is key right like you don't
even have to be confident you just need
to look confident right but like
confidence will get you where you want
to be in this world right believing in
yourself and so one of the things that's
kind of given here and even one of the
things that mary jane watson discusses
is this idea that this this institution
right alcor is basically a place where
they like experiment on animals they
conduct a lot of heinous research here
right a lot of terrible terrible things
all in the pursuit of science and so one
of the crazy things about this is that
unlike days past when peter was more of
the the curious one right the one who
would stray off the beaten path in order
to find his own way or to kind of go
into that room and feel you know to kind
of see what's going on what you actually
get here is mary jane watson that leads
him into a restricted section it's one
of these things where like her goal is
to save animals right to save as many
animals as they possibly can and so
peter actually ends up reaching into a
into a container that holds an
irradiated arachnid female and of course
it bites him when that happens mary jane
watson of course has a rabbit because of
the fact that they entered the room and
basically started messing with stuff it
activated the entire alarm system and
security shows up and so while they're
kind of being interred there mary jane
watson's parents of course come and pick
her up peter parker's parents are dead
right that's one of the things he says
is like his parents are dead and he
basically lives with uncle ted who's
basically a stand-in for uncle ben
because seemingly aunt may's not really
part of the picture and we're not really
giving an explanation as to why his
aunt's not there but we can largely
assume that they are basically separated
right that they basically split up and
we'll get more of an explanation as to
why that's the case here in a second but
mary jane watson having lived next to
peter parker it's kind of like look you
know he can come home with us right i
mean they have to release him to like an
adult guardian but it's like he can come
home with us it's fine you know
everything's gonna be cool and so when
he gets back home that's when his uncle
ted shows up and what you end up finding
out is that peter parker is the the way
that he is because of the abuse he
sustains at the hands of his uncle so
for those of you guys who aren't really
familiar with this kind of stuff the old
adage is that sociopaths are made and
psychopaths are born and for the most
part that's kind of old hat that stuff
doesn't really apply anymore and even
the term sociopath and psychopath are
considered antiquated terms that by and
large the notion of a psychopath versus
a sociopath just kind of fall under the
umbrella of antisocial personality
disorder and a lot of that's because the
various attributes of the two cross over
in a lot of ways right like a psychopath
lacks the ability to feel remorse a
psychopath lacks the ability to feel
empathy a sociopath can feel empathy and
where psychopaths may be a lot more
controlled a lot more manipulative far
more planning and their approach to
different situations sociopaths will be
far more hot-headed right they'll be
impulsive different things like that at
the end of the day both of them can be
made right there are genetic components
to a psychopath but it's not necessarily
that way that peter here looks to be a
classic case of what we would call a
sociopath right that he was made this
way and the reason why is because his
uncle's head is highly abusive right
that he considers peter to basically be
this kind of goofball this kind of kid
who's always problematic and even goes
as far as to say that he never should
have let social services talk him into
taking peter in and so we actually beat
peter and while that's happening because
mary jane watson lives across the street
she hears it happening right it brings
tears to her eyes but she hears peter
begging as his uncle just beats him
right on a daily basis now when that
happens or at least following that at
least the next day anyway the kind of
impulses that peter begins to experience
as a result of the spider bite begin to
manifest now this is where things
totally change because in the main
marvel universe and really most
alternate reality stories that involve
peter parker or some variation of peter
parker whether it's uh you know
spider-gwen or somebody like that the
the whole process of him becoming
spider-man usually manifests in the fact
that one he feels more confident he
feels more energetic right like as if
he's just been working out his entire
life and is just now feeling the effects
of it as well as the traditional things
that you're used to seeing him crawling
on walls his spider sense different
things along those lines in this
instance whether it's because of his
upbringing or something along those
lines the powers that begin to manifest
actually fall in the range of more
violent and dark abilities right in the
sense that like he experiences a kind of
hunger and so as a result of this he
actually ends up grabbing a mouse that
was caught in a mousetrap and
essentially consumes it following that
he goes after a cat and then in turn
when the cat scratches him and begins to
get away he ends up shooting his webbing
by accident realizing that he has it and
snares the cat and then realizes he can
make a kind of home for himself right in
the same way that a spider will fashion
a web peter begins the same thing here
and so what ends up happening is later
on that night of course uncle ted comes
home and things happen exactly as you
would expect them to right and some of
you might even watch this like yeah man
it's about time uncle ted got his due
right so ultimately uh when uncle ted
comes in of course the lights are out
the whole thing's done he's pissed off
that peter doesn't have dinner ready
when he gets into his room he basically
finds all these different just kind of
cocoon type things right basically all
these animals from around the
neighborhood that have basically been
ensnared by peter that he's essentially
saving as meals and that's what spiders
do right spiders will catch an object or
catch a thing that shows up in their web
or at least activates their web they'll
ensnare it and then sometimes they'll
eat it immediately other times they'll
store it for later use but regardless
peter is just laying in weight basically
attached to his ceiling and then
immediately goes after his uncle ted
right now following that you basically
end up picking up with him as he's
making his way to school and of course
you've got all these posters for missing
cats and different things along those
lines right animals that had vanished
and then flash thompson shows up right
flash thompson starts giving him a hard
time having no idea that peter is
basically eating a bird that he had kept
away in his locker which is really kind
of weird but with flash thompson giving
him a hard time kind of making fun of
him that sort of a thing you know
ultimately peter kind of does exactly
what you've seen over the course of the
traditional spider-man mythos where he
stands up to flash thompson with this
new vow of confidence the difference
here is that unlike peter who usually
gets in some kind of a fight with flash
overpowers him and then basically
demonstrates i'm not someone to be
trifled with in this instance he kills
flash thompson and he eats him right now
you don't actually see it happen instead
it's alluded to right flash says like
you won't be laughing when i wipe that
grin off your face with my fist and then
in turn peter's like you know we'll name
a time and a place and flash says okay
well then how about during lunch right
out in like the in the the locker room
and so it's like lunch that sounds
perfect right and so given what we've
seen so far peter's basically going to
eat flash thompson now following that of
course again after school making his way
back to his home he ends up coming
across a kid who's putting up a poster
looking for his pet peter leads him back
to his house and then ultimately seems
to consume that kid as well and so all
this comes to a head with mary jane
showing up at his house last night and
the reason why is because flash thompson
hasn't shown up right she doesn't know
where he is he usually always calls that
kind of a thing and peter kind of
dismisses it insofar as just being like
i mean what do you ever see in that guy
anyway right you know it's kind of like
you know a guy was always a jerk like
why would you date somebody like him you
know and so there is almost kind of a
romantic moment right with this sort of
new confidence that peter has again much
like you would normally see in the main
spider-man mythos he makes a move on
mary jane watson the difference here is
that after kissing her he immediately
bites her and of course with that in
mind when she smacks him and just
basically knocks away part of the skin
on his face you actually see what he's
ended up becoming under his skin that he
is basically a giant human spider i mean
he's got like eight eyes and just like
these mandibles coming out of his mouth
and all kinds of crazy stuff right of
course mary jane watts is terrified for
her life ends up stumbling into his room
to find his uncle strapped to the bed
peter's basically just been feeding on
him all this time and then the kid that
he had kidnapped earlier is basically
strung upside down with peter having the
intention to feed on him at a later date
right i mean i told you guys man this
story gets dark dude it's it is dark
now the funny thing about this is that
in this whole process as mary jane is
trying to like get away from peter right
he's kind of stalking her a little bit
and she's begging for her life and he's
like look i'm i wouldn't hurt you like
why would i why would i kill you now
that's that's never gonna happen you
know like you know he's like today like
i'm a carrier right you're gonna be the
mother of my children and that's when
you end up finding out that what he had
done with uncle ted is he had actually
deposited spider eggs in him and all
those spider eggs just come pouring out
of him right his mouth his ears his eyes
the whole nine yards just come dumping
out of the sky they immediately go and
try to try to basically swarm mary jane
and then of course that basically leads
to the arrival of moreland now here's
the thing about this this again
ties into the nature of spider-verse
that morlan is one of the inheritors and
what these guys are doing is just
traveling around the multiverse killing
everybody who is basically some
variation of spider-man it doesn't
matter who they are or what they are and
that's kind of the irony behind this is
because under normal circumstances when
you look at the edge of spider-verse
stories or even the lead-up to
spider-verse that mourlon was basically
a bad guy right killing these spider-men
who were heroes who were just trying to
do the right thing in this instance he's
kind of more of a good guy right now
he's a good guy by circumstance as long
as though he somehow changed his tune
decided to become a hero killing off all
the different evil spiderman across the
multiverse it just happens to be this is
a universe where peter parker ended up
becoming some giant twisted version of a
human spider and was about to kill mary
jane and he showed up and just happened
to rescue her right the funny thing
about this is that when you're talking
about somebody like morlon and this is
something that we've seen consistently
this dude's on a whole different level
this this kid right i mean he's only
been spider-man or at least been a
spider-man s character for like a couple
days or something like that so quite
literally more lon tears this kid apart
i mean he rips his arm off he tears the
mandibles out of his face i mean he he
just wrecks this kid right and in turn
just absorbs all the life force from him
and basically kills him in the process
and so following that what you end up
doing is picking up with mary jane
watson the next day and so as she's kind
of getting ready for school and all that
kind of stuff you basically end up
having her looking at this bite that she
has from peter parker and then suddenly
there's movement only for a baby spider
to crawl out and suddenly for like all
these spiders to come dumping out of
this opening presumably to consume mary
jane watson alive but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end yeah man this is dark
and i will catch you all later
peace